that was before the war 1938 but the war
was already preparing itself and
Czechoslovakia was broken up and part of
it was taken over by hungry and broad
where I was living where my mother and I
and my grandparents my father's parents
were living became hungry and we're and
my mother then decided to go back to
where her parents lived in Houma no it
was in Slovakia now another country
nobody told me that my father died
that much I know my mother came back
from the hospital and was a subject that
was never brought up I look at this
picture this is a picture of my mother
and me this is a passport picture like
you doesn't like you to see this you
have it
hold it still all the longer can you
talk while you're holding yes I look at
I looked at this picture just a few
weeks ago and both my mother and I
really looked happy here but I remember
when this picture was taken and I was
just I was very very sad this was my
second father you are how old when you
had another father I was five years
after my father died 1940 1940 you have
that okay it's okay
and he was he was just a beautiful man
he loved me and he really made a home
for both my mother and me for a while
their life for us was just really
beautiful I had a bicycle
it's me on a bicycle
and I had a dog and a car
and I was surrounded by all dozens of
cousins there was my mother's family and
then there was my second father's family
with aunts and uncles and that really
was a joyous life lasted about a year
just thinking back on it and so and then
the war began and we wore Jewish stars
and I remember my mother telling me that
this is something that should make me
very proud because because Jews were
very special it's sort of my first
awareness of being a Jew and then they
began to take the deportations began
from Slovakia now what happened then I
remember very clearly there was a priest
in Romania a Greek Orthodox priest
and the law a law was passed that
anybody who had converted to
Christianity before 1938 would be exempt
from being deported he agreed to put on
the list of people who had been
converted
any Jew who wanted to be there to fake
the list but he insisted that the
children be fully baptized legally
converted to Greek orthodoxy and so my
parents chose to do that and I was
converted to be a Christian that was I
remember the holy water being poured
over my head and from that time I have a
vision
it was either a dream or a vision I'm
not sure which but it the whole image is
very clear in my mind this is the image
I'm on a meadow and there are Jewish
kids playing around me and at one point
they move away from me and I'm alone on
this meadow and God appears before me
and he's a mountain and God holds in his
hand an axe and it just goes it takes
the axe over his head and with a full
swing splits me in half I just break
into two
to do in question I think it's more like
killing me like punishment it doesn't
feel like chewing Christian it feels
like annihilation that's what it feels
like
and I remember we were in an attic of a
Gentile friend of the family and I saw
through a little crack in the window
Jews being herded towards the railroad
station and and this was over we went
out we came down again and all the other
Jews somehow came back that were not
deported and we were there were some
children of us and we went looking to to
the houses that people were deported
reported from and we went to the house
of the short cut the short cut from home
and he lived in a very small house the
window was so low to the ground that
even as a small child I was able to look
through it and inside there was nothing
but rubble everything was broken up and
all over the floor there were his little
books that he used to tear off tickets
from to give you as a receipt for the
chickens that you took to him to kill
some blue some red green and ah I
remember all I wanted to do was just get
one of these books for myself they
looked very desirable and then I crawled
in through the window I took some of the
books and
somehow then I realized that this man
was taken away sometime around this
point my aunt uncle and their son my
cousin were taken to constantly ported
also and were taken to concentration
camp and my father brought them back had
them brought back spent a lot of money
he himself went to the Polish border
they were in a Polish concentration camp
Lublin I thought it was that's that
that's the name that's in my mind about
that and at that point I knew that all
these deportations ended up in the
killing of Jews I just I knew that I
that the realization that people were
being killed comes from that period that
was very early in the war it was
probably 1942 a lot of the kids a lot of
the children from Slovakia who had the
opportunity were at this point being
smuggled to Hungary to safety and so my
mother asked me if I wanted to go and so
in the train left and I was sitting on
the train with the smuggler a woman I
was being smuggled across this her son I
remember I was really filled with
excitement I saw the train leavin her
staying behind on the platform waiting
to me
we crossed the border and we the train
arrived in a city called quash Itza
which is the largest city around I think
it had around 70 thousand people then
and when we arrived there the woman the
smuggler
took me by the hand and said now you
just get off the platform look for a
policeman and whatever they ask you just
tell them that your parents are dead
and that you don't know where they are
and you don't know where you're coming
from and everything will be fine and at
the end of the day somebody came from
the Jewish orphanage and took me into
the orphanage and in retrospect I now
know what the plan was my grandfather
wanted to adopt me legally and in
Hungary things were still very legal and
so he wanted me to be officially in the
orphanage and then he began proceedings
to adopt him legally then I remember
when my grandfather came to get me and
it was like suddenly there was a there's
suddenly everything blossomed as if life
opened up I was suddenly again brought
into this warm family this is a picture
of me right after I came out of the
orphanage I was um they took me to a
store where they bought me new clothing
and this is a picture of my cousin av AV
K and me I am not quite 8 7
this is 1942 this is 43 43 in the spring
and to synagogue every Friday every
Saturday but Madhava was a very small
town and everybody knew everybody a very
warm place went to soccer games every
Sunday
I went to school there
and then the Germans invaded Germans
invaded Hungary they well they just
walked in and and it became immediately
everything that things were going to be
bad for the Jews tells 19 1944 I was in
great I was in second grade and I had a
teacher his name was bollock it was my
teacher in second grade it's a very tall
man his hair was was completely
plastered smooth on his head with a part
in the middle and he made a speech I was
just sitting there and he started to
make a speech and a speech began
something like this he said black crows
invaded our country many years ago and
they were eating away at the flesh and
blood of our country and these crows
were the Jews and he pointed right at me
it's horrifying and I was very scared
and I was also very very angry I
remember my anger and that they his son
was in the playground and my cousin was
there I love my cousin she was a year
younger than me and bollocks son started
to beat my my cousin she pushed her off
the swing and I got furious and I just
jumped on him and pushed his face no and
in the mud and I really beat him up and
the next day I was in class again with
Pollak his father
and his father said started to make
another speech he said pointed me let me
top it of each it said beat up my son
who is weaker than he is but I am glad
that he did that because that will even
that will reinforce his hatred for the
Jews I don't know what got into me but I
got up and I said Oleg or I said mr.
Bhalla if you're so glad I'm gonna beat
him up again and he lunged and he picked
me up from the seat and he tossed me
across the room it's very scary
this was Pesach it was the second day of
Pesach and during the day I remember one
of the policemen came to warn my
grandfather that we were going to be
gathered and then deported that night
and so I remember my grandfather took
the jewelry and they buried it someplace
but this is a very clear scene in my
mind they sort of kept it secret they
didn't want to see me to see where it
was being buried and that night we were
all herded together and herded into the
synagogue they took us from the
synagogue to the railroad station and we
were we all had just small bags
suitcases and all the people from the
village were standing around watching us
leave the Jews that were living that
lived there probably four six seven
hundred years
Moldova for all now leaving were you
wearing any identification as Jews no
never be worn no stars we just marched
serving between them to the railroad
station in at the railroad station they
put us into cattle cars freight trains
close the doors and they took us to cos
it's the big city where my cousin Lee
and they prepared a ghetto there I heard
all the Jews together and we lived there
for three weeks this was happening all
over Hungary they were bringing all the
Jews from the smaller villages smaller
towns into the big center centers ready
for deportation to Auschwitz three times
Smuggler's King my father later told me
that at this point he was ready to go
for me and he had a he had borrowed he
had rented or bought a priest suit and
he was going to dress as a priest in
come cross the border and come and get
me and I know he would have been just he
was he loved me the fourth time the
smuggler came was just at the time and
they were already gathering us for the
trip to the railroad station to
Auschwitz there was a flat car a flatbed
truck and the belongings were being
piled on it and the smuggler came and I
remember this we were in the apartment
and there was all the rushing back and
forth and getting packed to leave and my
grandfather came to me he looked at me
and he said you will not go back to your
mother
and he said we will probably not come
back and I'm going to tell you where we
buried our jewel jewels and you make
sure that you tell your mother where
that was where that is
and it gives me goodbye and I left I
played with the ball past the German
guards miss Mugler was waiting for me
outside the ghetto and just to bounce
the ball past the German guards and
Hungarian guards and the English that
was that and my cousin who was with her
parents she had noticed nobody was there
to take her away and her parents
probably wouldn't have let her go
families wanted to stay together and she
was taken into concentration camp and
she was separated from my aunt my aunt
and uncle survived the war as she was
killed all my cousins were killed my
grandparents were killed the smuggler
caressed got me to the border it was not
dark and the river the river was the
border and he left me he went to
recognizer to see which way we could
cross and he came back is and he said I
have to leave you here for a while
because the place where I usually cross
is not safe
I'll be back for you and so he left me
and there was a meadow and facing me and
there were woods behind me and I was
hiding behind the bush and it got dark
and I waited and I was there most of the
night alone and I remember being there
hidden behind that bush there were dogs
barking on the border I was about 200
meters from the border I don't remember
any fear but but it must have been very
scary
he came for me and we crossed the border
and we met my father on the other side
of the border who was waiting for me
there took me home
and and the scene that I remember is
that he was so moved my father that he
just cried and cried and hugged me for a
long time then he put me on his bicycle
and we bicycle to the train station and
he got on the train they took me back to
home in there and I remember getting off
the train and there was a long street
and the other stand of Sun at the other
end of the street was my mother and my
dog the one I show this picture I showed
you and the dog just started galloping
towards me and he just jumped on him for
such as so great to be with them and the
first thing I told my mother he'd be
away for how long
a year a little over a year the first
thing I had to tell my mother was where
the gold was buried it was such a weight
on to carry this message and so I told
her I felt a great relief I've given
that message
there was an uprising in the centre of
Slovakia this was now middle of 1944
summer of 1944 and we headed towards the
center of Slovakia which was under the
control of the partisans who rebelled
against the Germans and we got there and
my father joined the partisans and that
was a terrific sight he had he had a
uniform and he had a gun
not really looked great and we lived
there for two months and then the the
uprising was betrayed by the Russians
this is this what they did and I
remember this is not something that I
know from afterwards I know it from them
that the Russians were coming and then
they stopped and I remember the panic
when everybody suddenly realized that
the Russians stopped coming to stop and
waited for the uprising to be defeated
to be wiped out because they didn't want
any independent and independent leaders
to continue it and the Germans came
again and I remember my mother and I got
up got on a train which was sort of the
last train out of this place and my
father was still in uniform I had a
truck available to him and he drove with
the truck and I remember getting on the
train which is absolutely crowded and
there was a young man on the train not
twenty-five and be so many saw my mother
and me he started shouting get those
Jews off this [ __ ] train and he
started kicking my mother and just
pushing her off the train and somebody
stopped him pulled him away so we stayed
on the train but that's it that is still
such a powerful thing
anger just tremendous anger
and I hope he some somebody bashed his
head him we got to where the train was
going which was sort of the beginning of
the Tatra mountain ranges then we got
off the train we met my father and we
started hiking into the woods into the
mountains along the way we were attacked
by some German planes started shooting
at us so we stayed together and we
wanted some more and finally we came out
on some road and the road was filled
with refugees people were just wandering
through the countryside and we joined
them and we used to meet my mother and I
and my father every day in the park and
after about 2 or 3 weeks in the city
my father didn't show up and it was just
complete panic and my mother rushed over
to the place that he had lived and she
heard that he was so they had been
arrested and the following day we were
waiting in front of the police station
and he was marched out with about 30
other men I I saw him it was marched out
with soldiers around and my mother
started running after him right on it
running after them and he sent a message
back and the whole troop started to yell
get away get away they all stood to
start to shout at my mother so my mother
stopped and we quickly moved away it was
and we never saw my father again he was
taken to outside of the town and he was
shot I think back at my mother and she
was then she was then 20
and a woman who had never really you
know it was well from a sheltered
middle-class Jewish family and she rose
to this tremendous event and we
essentially saved each other my mother
and I we lived together and she relied a
lot on me on my advice but she was
brilliant in just the way she maneuvered
and manipulated our survival and that's
at that point we had very little money
she had to get a job some of the things
that happened to her time came to get
new phosphate new papers because every
year you had to get a new identity cards
we had to she had to exchange her old
one so she came she went to the police
station she told me that the policeman
there had called her aside and asked her
to come into the inner office and told
her listen I know you're not enough it's
a cover I know Anna hits October I know
the she and I were lovers but I like you
and I'll keep you safe if you and I can
be friends if you if you'll stay with me
and so my mother promised that she would
so she came out she did get her identity
card and immediately that afternoon we
packed up and we left
and we left for a place called
Bratislava which is which was the
capital city Slovakia and we didn't know
anybody and we were we had very little
money and we had no coupons for food we
arrived in Bratislava in the evening and
we were sitting at the railroad station
on a wooden bench my mother and I and so
trying to figure out what to do and at
this point a beautiful young girl came
up to us she was 20 no she was funny
because she told me she told us so and
she said you know you look like you need
some help and my mother said yes we have
no place to stay and she just took us
into her apartment she had she lived
ironically on Jadhav skowl itza which
means the Jews street does the old
jewish ghetto then when my mother got
this job at the tailors and one day a
german officer came in and he I would
say fell in love but he wanted my mother
and he invited us for supper and I was
petrified so as my mother
my mother said no no we don't need any
help and she went out to see if she
could buy tickets to get out of this
place that night we immediately left her
brackish lava we just got on a train and
again just just moved out and this time
we just we got off the train remember
the scene it was raining again and
snowing and cold and all we had was
summer clothing we couldn't afford an
even they couldn't buy any winter
clothes and we got off the train just
got off the train at a place never heard
of it before and we were very hungry
and we went into the restaurant the
train station restaurant we sat down to
eat something and there were three
Slovak policemen there and one of the
policemen called me over and he said to
me spaz do you dish and I said what are
you saying but is that what I pretended
that I didn't know and he said I'll go
away and then I heard them speak to each
other and he said one of the policemen
said to the other one he said you know I
know that these people are Jews but I
really want to help them so when my
mother came back I told her that I want
to speak to her outside I have to show
her something and I said you know I
overheard these people these soldiers
and they know we're Jews but they want
to help us and I think this is the right
thing to do so we went back and my
mother spoke to the policeman and he
said I'll take you someplace where you
will be safe
and the three of us the police one
policeman and my mother and I we started
walking and we walked for about ten
kilometers through a little path and he
fled to a very small village where it
was right at the foot of the mountains
there maybe a hundred people in it and
he went to the mayor of this small town
of hamlet and he said that he will leave
us with him and he wants us to be safe
there then one day there was explosion
and and guns and fighting and we hid
into it in a cellar and then next thing
we knew a Russian soldier came into the
bunker and the war was over and we left
and we came back to where we had to
where we had lived before the war and
hardly anybody else came back for just
one last question your conversion what
did it leave you with what is there what
currently yeah just a vague feeling of
ility sness a vague feeling that I
should go someplace and undo it but
there is no mechanism for that
what I would like to just show you tell
you is just one other thing and that is
that during the same period
two years ago when I was down in the
chasm the feeling that overwhelmed me
was that there were people who only
lived in my memory that I was the only
link to the world for these poor people
the shortage of whom Nara and the
feeling was just so awful but what I did
was I called him my son I'm still in bed
then and I said what I want you to do is
hear about the shortcut of home in it so
that you will also remember him and I
told him about the shortcut of home in
it and my son said to me okay I will
remember